Game of Thrones Gilly has been
surprising us from her first episode and
as the series finale and all the battle
and bloodshed it brings with it crests
the horizon she's not likely to stop
anytime soon how might the young woman
from Craster's keep turned the tide of
battle if you're all caught up on your
Game of Thrones binges then you've
probably grown accustomed to seeing
Gilly embarking on ocean voyages or in
the relative safety of the Citadel it
might be easy to forget that Gilly spent
most of her life in the dangerous lands
beyond the wall she knows the north like
only a wildling could and she holds no
illusions about how desperate life there
can be while season seven ended with the
walkers shattering the wall in a
spectacular burst of Blue Dragon Fire it
seems likely that at least part of the
final season could take place in the far
north and Gilly could prove a unique
guide to those frozen and forbidding
lands not to mention that while most
Game of Thrones central characters have
until now seen the White Walkers is
nothing more than some laughable child's
tale Gilly grew up with the walkers as
an absolute certainty they were a part
of her daily life as one of Craster's
wives
the walkers appetites defined her life
and she understands them as few can in
the season 7 finale one of the most
popular fan theories was confirmed by
Bram stark and his psychic time spanning
visions it turns out that Jon Snow isn't
a bastard at all but the child of
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark which
means that Daenerys isn't the last
Targaryen and John is the true heir to
the Iron Throne but before bran peeled
back the layers of time and space there
was Gilly discovering it in a forgotten
journal buried in the bowels of the
Citadel in the season 7 episode east
watch as she and Sam pored over the
spoils of the Citadel's library Gilly
found the description of an annulment
granted to Jon Snow's true father may
nod says here that he issued an
annulment for Prince Rhaegar and
remarried into someone else at the same
time not only was she the first person
to stumble onto this explosive fact she
is now one of the few people who knows
it at all in a sense the moment Gilly
discovered it she became one of the most
dangerous people in Westeros
Yuni
worried about you regardless of his
noble birth Sam was never going to be
heir to horn Hill he's a sensitive and
scholarly man who doesn't live up to his
father's narrow standards Sam is no
longer part of house Tarly having
forsworn his claim for the Nights Watch
and disowned by his tyrant of a father
since Sam's father and brother Dickon
were executed by Daenerys for refusing
to bend the knee technically Sam's
sister Tala is now the heir and Lady of
horn Hill but let's be honest the letter
of the law doesn't count for much in
Westeros what matters is who shows up
who fights the hardest and who has
something to show for it he may be quiet
and bookish but Sam has killed a white
Walker smuggled Royals across Kingdom
lines sworn to protect Gilly and her
child and helped uncover a decades-old
secret he drove a dagger into the wok is
hot he risked his own life to save mine
more than once he's a great to worry
than either of you will ever be Sam
absolutely could end up as the lord of
horn Hill and if he did that would make
Gilly his lady and baby Sam the air horn
Hill is fabulous even by the standards
of noble houses and has been cozy with
other families of the reach for decades
this wouldn't just be an incredible
place of power for an abused wildling
girl but an incredible place of power
period whew Game of Thrones characters
have travelled as far as Gilly
she began in the fearsome world north of
the wall where she shared her home with
massive Giants in the growing army of
the dead she spent time at Castle black
where she made a home among her enemies
Gilly has feasted in the opulent halls
of corn hill learned to read in the
legendary Citadel and is now in
residence at Winterfell alongside the
reunited remnants of the stark family
few characters in Game of Thrones
specially commoners have been as far or
has met so many powerful people Gilly
has connections to the common folk of
Westeros as well as the giant noble
houses she may have begun as a simple
wildling girl but now she's the Maypole
around which multiple ribbons of plot
and character or wound the show's final
season will reveal which ribbon tugs the
strongest check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]